[Music]
let's go to
danny
is that it danny all right danny in
billings montana what's up danny how we
doing
hey dr john how are you so good how
about you
i am hanging in there
that sounds
come on hanging in there
it's pretty cold so you know do what you
can do oh how cold is it
um it's like five right now nope
nope
nope there are some people who believe
in hell and people who believe in hell
think hell is hot and i might disagree
because you know what hell sounds like
five degrees five that's what's that
planes trains and automobiles he's like
alcohol is it out here one
ah five degrees okay so yes i can see
you're hanging on there that's not great
so other than that though what's going
on
yeah so um i'm calling because um so i'm
24 years old i love you now i love the
way you're dancing around this this
is so good okay so you're 24
yep i've been married now for about six
months
um and two months into
my husband matt and my marriage we um
took custody of his two kids so full
custody of his six-year-old and
ten-year-old from his previous marriage
and i
i don't know i'm just kind of here and
going along with it and figuring it all
out so before that um they're from
alabama and so we
were just kind of there with them what
do you what do you mean you're going
along with it
they're your kids that's your husband
what do you mean
yeah yeah are you are you not a huge fan
um i
never really thought say it out loud say
it out loud are you not a huge fan i
mean
i mean i'm not i mean i love them
um but i never thought i was gonna have
kids and so part of the reason
that i think it was so appealing to be
with him is because he didn't want any
more kids and then had these two
wonderful kids to live with their mom
who was doing really awesome
and then she fell into um opiate
addiction and so now they're with us
full-time so they've gone through a
whole lot
and
i'm going through it too yeah
so you've got two
kids who've i mean they've got a lot of
trauma coming yeah to move with in with
that in the middle of the year
from alabama to
five degrees
to new mom who's 24 how much older is he
than you
he's 31 31 okay so stop that's not a lot
um okay you said
you said you didn't want kids but you
married a guy with two kids
it seems like the algorithm doesn't work
do what i know
they didn't live with us though and i
thought oh it'd be so great they're
going to be there we can be there and
support them
but not i guess be in it full time as
selfish as that sounds
and now
we're here and we're doing it all full
time and
doing all the extracurriculars and all
the schooling and taking them to
counseling and doctor's appointments and
all those things it's
a lot
so i can hear you smiling
almost so hard because if you stop
smiling you're going to start crying is
that where you're at
yep yeah
yeah
so
how can i help because yeah you're there
like it's here are you thinking about
leaving the marriage
um because i don't know what you signed
up for kind of
yeah but it's kind of what i've been
thinking about most of the time um
but these kids also so they lost their
stepdad to overdose
and so i'm
so scared to be
somebody else that leaves them after all
this trauma that they've been through
yeah but so it's also
i'm worried for them to have a
new maternal figure in their life that
doesn't like them
i mean i do love them and you love them
but you don't like what they've done to
your precious little life
yeah you know what i mean
yeah and it's just hard to accept that
and not feel so
selfish
why is it hard to accept that you
like
you married a guy with two kids and now
those two kids are there and
like this is our life now
like what do you think you're missing
out on
i think before we
had the kids with us here we were out
all the time adventuring and backpacking
and climbing and
we're just all over the place doing
everything and now we're
you know
taking the kids to taekwondo lessons and
going to dance lessons and it's just my
whole life has gone from doing what i
want to do when i want to do it to
living by this other schedule
yeah and so
it just feels like everything has
changed and my relationship has changed
so drastically
what's your husband say when you tell
him all this
um
so we just started marriage counseling
he's
i guess
understanding but worried
yeah he should be because his wife's
about to leave him
yeah
he should be real worried
yeah
and he's also got his fair share of of
mental health challenges he's a
he's a vet who has some some ptsd things
he's struggling with and so it's
just
i don't know it just all feels like a
mess all the time yeah
what part of this can you control
i can control how engaged i am with kids
and
i don't know i try to control it in the
most like microwaves like making sure
that they have the healthiest lunches
possible every single day
no no no no with with that you're
talking about duty and you have a duty
right now because you did you adopt them
were you part of the adoption
um no we we can't yet okay
have you started that process
no we have to wait quite a few years
okay so they're just living in full
custody with dad right now
correct okay so
back out before you start the duty stuff
you're playing mom right now and you're
playing caregiver you're basically being
like a like a big babysitter and
you were married for six months to
somebody and now that's all sideways
like
what can you control inside your own
head
all right let me let me ask another way
are you done
because if you're done say you're done
and say it out loud
if you
are grieving the fact that the world
just went sideways on you
i think you signed up for this that's
just what it sounds like you married a
guy with two kids and you can't be
stunned the two kids know
that the guy with two kids now has two
kids
um but it is a different arrangement
than you and your
heart
were hoping for
um but
you can either just be done and walk
away or you can grieve this it's a mess
it's not what it was we used to be able
to run the world and do everything and
now our world is different
and now
how do we make desire how do we practice
desire how do we love one another how do
we have crazy fun adventures and hikes
and crazy fun sex and crazy fun stuff
and still raise a ten-year-old and
six-year-old like how do we do those
things together
um
or
like man i'm out
like it feels like those are your two
choices
or the third one is which help the third
one is actually what most people choose
danny which is i'm just gonna stay in
this and be miserable for the rest of my
life that's how most people do it
yeah it's kind of where i feel like i am
right now like teetering on this
decision
don't choose misery
yeah don't
so convince me that these two kids and
that your husband that you loved a lot a
few months ago
um convince me they're not worth
creating a brand new wild adventure for
your life
like what are you missing
um
i guess
let me get this way here let me ask this
way so i used to live in houston in a in
a big city and
in my head i was always going to
concerts and astros games and sporting
events and things like that
then we moved out to west texas where
there's not a major sports team there's
college teams and things like that but
i'd always talk to my wife about wanting
to get back to the city back to the city
back to the city back to the city
and then finally one day she just called
me on and said what what is it about the
city
and because our life's very similar to
what it was like no man the astros came
but
and she
she nailed me up to the wall using uh
data
i went to about one or two games a year
and i went
like on a big fishing trip to the b like
to galveston like once a year
and i went to concerts like two or three
times a year yeah and i did those same
things in west texas because i would
drive to houston and i'd go to like two
concerts we'd go to astros game and i'd
go fishing like so my life really hadn't
changed
my
fantasy about what my life used to be
that's what changed
yeah
hear what i'm saying
so what would you
what are you actually missing
i think
what i'm missing the most is a world
that's not
controlled by other people so we're
still in all of this court stuff in and
out and
it just feels like every
day all my decisions are being made by
somebody else
okay unpack that all your decisions
brushing your teeth
no when you go to the bathroom
no where are you going to the bathroom
gross go in the bathroom don't be
disgusting like go on an actual potty uh
i said potty because i have a
five-year-old that's ridiculous i meant
to say toilet i live in the woods though
so
you can i live in the woods too it's so
great you can go wherever you want to
man
um do you have pets
we don't
okay who decided that
see like the the all language what what
what decisions are being decided for you
i guess my general daily schedule
outside of work and personal time okay
like um
like
what i'm doing in the evenings
what i'm doing on the weekends okay what
are those what are those things
like
taekwondo
um and doing have you ever taken
taekwondo no
how incredible would it be if you signed
up for taekwondo you'd become a ninja
i mean i guess my kid really likes it
yes
so here's what i'm saying here here's
what i'm getting at here's what i'm
getting at okay and i'm trying to smile
through it because i know it's hard for
you okay
um
here's the thing
the world took a left turn on you
for whatever reason whatever we you and
i could debate all day long whether
what your role in this is
i think it's high you think it's
probably low who that's a fun drinking
game
more real more important is here's where
you're at
yeah
and your ultimate question is what am i
going to do next
am i going to leave my husband who i
loved a few months ago
um in our fantasy life that we lived as
a 24 year old
um
i didn't want kids and now i've got two
even though i'm married again with two
kids
and i got now i got two and i'm making
lunches and i
have to ask myself am i gonna trade the
random camping trip or the random hiking
trip
for taekwondo
classes am i going to trade sitting on
the couch watching netflix for taking
kids to school
am i going to trade
ordering in
doordash for making a healthy dinner for
you know for having my kids teaching
kids how to make dinner for themselves
and all of us doing that together you're
gonna have to yourself ask yourself that
but what i don't want you to do is to
use words like all and everything and no
more and those big
catastrophic end of times words because
they're uh they're they're almost always
not true
so here's your homework assignment are
you ready
i am homework assignment number one i
don't think you've fully told your
husband how bad things are have you
it's starting to come out in counseling
but yeah so you haven't told him i'm not
there yet you need to look him in the
eye and say i'm considering leaving you
if you are indeed doing that
or if you need to say out loud
my whole world exploded i know yours did
too this is not what i signed up for and
i'm working through what it's going to
look like for me to be here that's a
fair thing to say that's an honest thing
to say and you need to say that out loud
because then you both can work on what
that looks like if you just him haul
around and like i don't know i'm just
thinking about
man that gets messy and he thinks he's
he's helping out and he's not because
he's not getting at the root issue okay
and by the way you're gonna make him
crazy because he's gonna think he's the
problem
and the problem right now is your
choices and then the third thing is i
want you to write down these stories
because you've got a lot of stories in
your head
stories about what you wanted for your
life what happened to you what's fair
what's not fair i don't have any time
left i've got no whatever left all my
whatever i want you to write those
stories down every one of them
and then i want you to draw a line
across the page and demand evidence is
this one true
is every one of my decisions now over no
am i able to pack up and go camping
anymore no i'm not allowed to do that
anymore because i got two ten-year-old
and six-year-old
can we get babysitters and still go
camping can we after
you know the shock of two a ten-year-old
and a six-year-old joining our house can
we get back to a great sex life can we
get back to date nights can we get back
to these things and answer all that is
yes it's just if you want to work for it
or not
yeah
yeah and so my question for you is this
are you do you want to work are you
going to or not
i i think you're out
yeah i don't know yet
i hope you're not
i hope you will
create a whole new adventure and you'll
stick it out i really do and not just
because of the kid i mean there's
there's all that but
for you i think you've got a monster
adventure ahead of you
of course it's going to be hard and
brutal and completely different than you
thought
but man
it could be so much better than you
could have ever dreamt
but it sounds to me like you're done man
yeah
yeah
i don't know yet
i see i don't believe you i think you do
know and you don't want to say it out
loud and that's fair i won't force you
to do it on the on the internets on the
podcast
i want you to practice i want you to
pretend you're staying
pretend you're staying
for 30 days
and go all in and all in means you're
gonna be honest with your husband
going all-in means you're going to
attempt to get some skills that you
don't have right now
going all-in means you're going to
sign up for a class that you never
thought you would take like taekwondo
that you're going to get a cookbook i
don't know if you ever bought one of
those before whatever it is once you go
all in for 30 days and when you tell
your husband i'm going all in for 30
days but i'm really nervous be honest
with him
don't let him drown
all alone at the end of this thing
i think you got something awesome at the
end of this one
don't bail out danny
you